but... I don't know,
You know, I've talked about this,
the printer is upside down again,
and I...
Oh, no. Maybe I... Ah, yes.
Well, that works, actually. I can
read that fine. Um...
Right, let's... Yeah.
Good evening, um, let's get
straight to it.
We are now approaching Phase 46,
which means that from Tuesday
morning or Wednesday evening,
depending on your height, we are...
W-we are... W-we are...
We are saying, with regards to
baking - if you must bake in a tent,
bake in a tent, but please don't
bake in a tent. And... And...
And we are asking people to use
common sense with
regards to the distribution
of hundreds and thousands.
Now, I believe... I believe we have
a-a-a question
from the lady in the funky dress.
Noel, yes.
Hello, Prime Minister. Yes?
Just one quick question, is
it "scone" or "scon"?
Right, well, I'm... I'm going to
hand over to the experts on this.
Uh, um, Prue Whitty.
"Scone".
Right, Professor Paul Hollywood.
"Scon".
Right, well, I hope that clears
things up for you.
All that remains is for me to say...
..welcome to
The Great British Bake Off!
My husband said to me, "Why don't
you apply?"
I was like, "I'm not going to get
in. I'm not going to get in."
I didn't give it a lot of thought,
I'll be honest with you.
I thought, "Oh, I'd love to go
on there."
This year's bakers will be part of
something very special.
Something about the year 2020 felt
as if it was kind of momentous,
possibly not in the way it's turned
out to be,
so I gave it a go.
Like everyone up
and down the country,
the Bake Off has had to make
some changes.
It's unbelievable that I'm living in
a wee Bake Off village,
a wee Bake Off town.
To save this year's competition,
the bakers have volunteered to
leave their loved ones and live
in our very own Bake Off bubble...
Actually harder than I thought
leaving home. So, the night before,
my husband cooked us fajitas,
or "fajeetas" as he calls them...
It just hit me. "I could not see you
for seven weeks."
And then I was like crying into
my dinner.
I come from a very loving family.
I miss them, but it has spurred
me on.
..and despite everything that this
year has thrown at all of us...
Once we all walk into the tent,
I think
it will get back to something very,
very familiar.
..we've made it.
Same old Bake Off - familiar,
comforting, lovely.
Would you like to dance with me?
12 new bakers...
Oh!
LAUGHTER
..30 brand-new spectacular
challenges...
Oh, go on, say you like it.
Actually, I love it, yeah. Yes!
..and in this unique year...
Have you done this before? Yes.
And did it work? Yes.
..we begin the competition
with a Cake Week...
It's given me quite a few sleepless
nights, this one.
..unlike anything The Bake Off has
ever seen.
I don't know
if I've ever fancied a cake before.
But I slightly do now!
Come on, Freddie.
Please stay together.
Some of Freddie Mercury's
head is not there.
GASPING
It's all gone wrong.
Oh, don't cry. It's all right!
It's so stressful, Paul.
Why on Earth did I get into this
competition? I don't know.
You chose to come here.
I know I did.
Urgh!
GASPING
Solid start.
We've taken a little detour,
and pitched our tent in
the beautiful grounds of Down Hall.
And our fresh batch of bakers are
about to tackle
three cake-based challenges,
after which we'll crown one of them
the first Star Baker of 2020,
and ask another to leave
The Bake Off tent.
Hello, bakers. Welcome to the tent,
and it's time for your first-ever
Signature Challenge.
The judges would like you to make
that fan favourite, the Battenberg.
Rectangular in shape
and wrapped in marzipan.
It can be any sponge you want,
any flavour,
but when you cut inside it, it needs
to reveal a pattern or a design.
You have just two hours.
You ready for those magic words?
Yes. Yes, I am.
OK, I'll set you up, yeah? OK.
You say it. All right, OK.
On your marks... BAKE!
LAUGHTER
That was a little bit early. Was it
a bit early? Leave a little bit...
A little bit of a gap. Bigger,
bigger gap. OK. All right.
Yep, yep, OK.
On your marks, get set...
..bake.
Maybe split the difference?
Split the difference? Split
the difference.
I've been so excited, I just
couldn't wait for it to begin.
Just raring to go.
# This is it! #
Very nice to get started,
I'm just...
Hopefully, I'm organised.
Stomach's kind of going like a bit
of a washing machine.
It's felt like I've sat around
waiting to get going all morning.
And I'm...
Do not know what has happened
to that.
I've broke something already.
Battenberg is a lovely signature
to kick off with.
Every marzipan lover's favourite
cake. Mine, too.
What I'm looking for is a beautiful,
smooth marzipan. Inside, stark
differences in colour of sponge.
I would keep it basic If I was them,
but make sure I'm punching with
flavours and punching with colours.
It's a real treat, it's very rich
cos of the marzipan.
And it should be wonderful.
I'm looking forward to it.
Good morning. Good morning, Loriea.
So, tell us about your Battenberg.
I'm making bubble gum and cream soda
flavoured Battenberg.
Bubble gum? Yeah.
How are you going to flavour it with
bubble gum? From a bottle.
And what's the other flavour?
It's a combination of cream soda
syrup and cream soda flavouring.
MATT: Loriea works as a radiographer
for the NHS,
and gets all her new recipes tested
by her neighbours in Durham.
Should have asked if you wanted
more, but... Thank you very much.
Her bubble gum and cream soda
sponges will be wrapped
in a bright blue marzipan.
What I love about this is you've
gone for everything that is
artificial. Yeah!
What I love about this is
absolutely everything.
Loriea's not the only baker
rediscovering her childhood.
Hello, Laura. Hello, how are you?
I'm all right, thanks.
How are you doing? I'm good, thanks.
What's happening?
I'm doing a raspberry ripple
Battenberg. One of the flavours
is raspberry ripple and the other
one is coconut.
Oh, lovely. And are you a big
Battenberg fan? Not really, mate.
No? No. I'm not a massive
fan of the marzipan.
Yeah, I don't think this will
go in the show,
but it's good to, you know, tell
people who you are, isn't it?
Laura is a Samaritans volunteer
from Halling, Kent, and takes huge
pride in the garden she's created
with her husband, Matt.
She plans to pipe buttercream
roses on her coconut
and raspberry ripple Battenberg.
You going to try some?
I will try some, but I'm not going
to judge it.
I have the eating age of
a nine-year-old.
Really? I'll just eat anything.
Oh, I just eat Super Noodles
and things like that.
There's nothing wrong with a good
Super Noodle. They're good,
aren't they? They are good.
You know they're called Batchelor's
Super Noodles? Yeah?
Cos I'm homosexual, I call them
"Confirmed Batchelor's
Super Noodles."
Are you a homosexual?
I never knew that.
Well, I help them out at weekends.
And there's one more baker who's
rolling back the years.
I am doing rhubarb and custard
Battenberg,
so there's a custard sponge,
and then the rhubarb jam
will go between, which I'm hoping
will be quite tart.
Are you doing a classic four square
design or...?
I don't want to show you what I'm
supposed to be doing
because I haven't got it right yet.
I'm trying to get a bit of a funky
star-shaped pattern.
Lottie lives in Littlehampton,
and unwinds from her job as
a pantomime producer by listening
to Viking metal whilst baking
and doing yoga with her
friend, Naomi.
Do you want to lift your arms
up? No.
For her take on
the old-fashioned sweet,
she'll attempt a striped marzipan to
surround her star-shaped
sponge, which there could already
be an issue with.
Why is it curdling?
The sponge has got lumps of
butter in.
I prefer it like that, to be honest.
It's because the butter was
too cold.
Do you think I should redo my
batter? Why?
Because it's got lumps of butter in
it. Show me.
You see? Yeah, redo it.
Redo it? I would. Oh, mate!
Solid start.
Just got to weigh out half of this.
The judges have demanded
Battenbergs featuring
at least two complimentary flavours.
Just adding cream soda into half of
the mixture.
I'm now running about
20 minutes behind.
And whilst Lottie has had to start
her trip to the sweet shop
all over again...
Nothing gradual about that.
..Dave's headed straight for
the off-licence.
The flavours today, I'm choosing to
do espresso martini.
Dave is an armoured security guard
from Hampshire, and he and his
partner Stacey are getting ready
for the arrival of their first baby.
One of his sponges will feature
chocolate and coffee liqueur,
and the other, in a Bake Off first,
will be flavoured with vodka.
Do you go off-piste
a lot, then? Yes.
Do you read a recipe and go,
"I'm not doing that"?
Just going to have to wing it.
Just see a recipe
as a loose sort of satchel...
It's a guide... of ideas.
It's a guide. Rules are meant to be
broken. Exactly.
They can't contain you.
You're a maverick.
But bold flavour combinations
aren't quite enough.
Need to get a good, deep red.
Key to Battenberg's success are
contrasting colours.
Some blue food colouring.
It just works.
But unlike Loriea...
I'm just making raspberry jam.
..some bakers are colouring their
cakes with something
a little less artificial.
I'm doing a sour cherry
and chocolate and walnut Battenberg.
These are the sour cherries.
It helps colour it
and give it flavour as well.
Marc lives in Cornwall.
He's a part-time carer
and full-time single dad to his
daughters Jasmine and Rosie.
Hey! Rose!
His sour cherry and chocolate
and walnut sponges will be
wrapped in a highly decorated
rose water marzipan.
Hello, Marc. Now, I've got
a question for you.
We have two "Marks" on the show.
Yeah. There's you and Mark.
Are you willing to surrender
your name?
I'll tell you what, I'll call myself
after my dog, Hamish.
Hamish? Yeah.
So, what would you normally be
doing? I work with a young lad.
Will he be watching this? He will
be. Yeah, yeah. What's his name?
His name is Josh. Josh? Hello, Josh.
How you doing? All right?
You should be very proud of Hamish.
Going into the oven.
The sooner the sponges begin
baking... One in each shelf.
..the sooner they can be cooled.
Stressful. A Battenberg requires
precise cutting and shaping.
Right, it's with the oven gods now.
Any attempt to trim a warm sponge
could see it fall apart.
Ah! Scary!
If I could stop shaking,
it would help.
Now, Matt, this is your first-ever
time calling out. I know.
You do it. I can't. You do it.
All right, I'll do it.
I'll do it. No, you do it.
You do it. BAKERS!
You have one hour left.
And then Paul Hollywood's coming.
Get it in the oven.
Please be good to me.
Deciding when to stop baking is
a crucial decision.
Yep, we're good to go.
The judges are expecting a sharp
geometric design...
Sponge is done.
..which demands sponges baked just
enough to hold their form when cut.
I'll give that another five minutes.
But baked a fraction too long
and the Battenberg's soft
texture will be lost...
Another two minutes... and Peter is
timing sponges unlike anyone else's.
It's a gluten-free sponge.
I'm actually more used to making
gluten-free than I am regular.
20-year-old Peter is a badminton mad
accountancy student from Edinburgh.
He began wheat-free baking for his
older brother Andrew who's
gluten intolerant.
High-quality back garden badminton.
His gluten-free dark chocolate
and orange sponges will be wrapped
in a polka-dot marzipan.
And he'll check them with
a trick he learnt
when he was just ten years old.
John Whaite on series three of
Bake Off,
he said that his mum taught him
to listen to it.
That if it's still wet, then it's
going to sound like
it's boiling away, but if it's just
a nice, moist cake,
it's just got a gentle, gentle
sound to it, so...
That was a good tip from Bake Off.
Sura probably won't need to
bake with her ears.
The cake is overflowing.
I didn't use this tin in practice,
cos it took three weeks to arrive.
Sura is a hospital pharmacist,
and lives in west London with her
husband Chad
and their cat Ghost.
What's that?
She'll have to transform her
overflowing sponges into a lemon
and orange Battenberg, complete
with mini marzipan fruits.
I feel sorry for whoever's going
to clean up after me.
Hello, Sura. You were a little bit
nervous earlier, weren't you?
You were thinking about starting
again. I wouldn't have had time.
Well, you wouldn't have the time.
Are you a Battenberg fan?
Will you be trying your own cake or
are you just like, "Nah,
"I'm not doing it."
I'm so over cake,
cos I've been tasting it
and trying it out.
Really? Yeah, I don't want to eat
any more cake ever again.
You might be on the wrong show,
Sura. Yeah, I know.
How long have we got left? Does
anyone know? About 40 minutes.
Now, the battle for Battenberg
gets even harder.
Very blue. What's life without
taking a little bit of risk? So...
These look overcooked,
but they feel relatively soft,
so I can work with that.
I can work with that.
This afternoon tea classic is famous
for its flawless
marzipan wrapping...
I'd never eaten marzipan, and they
were like, "You've got to try it."
I was like, "Mm-mm."
..and Paul and Prue have insisted
that the bakers make their own.
So, I've gone for a dark
green marzipan.
I'm doing a Turkish
bazaar-inspired Battenberg.
Me and my wife both love Istanbul.
It's actually my wedding
anniversary today,
so I thought it was quite a good...
It's actually worked out
quite a good time to do
the Battenberg. Yeah.
Mark is a project manager and lives
in Liverpool with his wife Laura.
BARKING AND LAUGHTER
Beneath his green marzipan will be
Turkish flavours of orange,
pistachio, cardamom and pomegranate.
So, have you spoke to your wife yet?
Anniversary?
I sent her a message earlier this
morning, but not since. Really?
Playing it cool.
Yeah, I'm playing it...
Not text her until she texts me.
Can't really play it cool once
you're married? You can't, no.
It's a done deal. It's done.
At least you didn't forget.
It's quite a busy day for you,
to be fair.
You're on Bake Off, first day,
and it's your anniversary. Exactly.
It's all stacked up against you.
It is.
You did really well! It is.
And Mark isn't alone in using
colour to elevate
the humble marzipan.
Well, I'm making my night
sky marzipan.
My great hero in music is Mozart.
His opera The Magic Flute - it's
all about the forces of darkness
and the forces of enlightenment,
so the outside of the cake is
the night sky which represents
the forces of darkness,
and then inside
is the temple of enlightenment.
This sounds genius.
How are you going to represent
a temple inside a Battenberg?
With a very complicated
lot of cutting.
Rowan is a music teacher, and lives
in Pershore, Worcestershire,
with his partner Paul.
Beneath his marzipan night sky,
his temple will be built from 13
separate sections of sponge.
And have you done this before,
Rowan? Yes.
And did it work? Yes.
NOEL LAUGHS
And if you thought a marzipan
night sky
and Battenberg temple
were unusual...
My Battenberg is going to be
shaped as an ambulance.
Linda works in supported housing
and lives in Bexhill-on-Sea with
her partner Richard.
Oh, that's lovely.
Her Battenberg ambulance will be
dedicated to a very special
family member.
It's going to be a tribute to
my cousin.
He was a paramedic.
He sadly passed away.
He was a fantastic guy, so this
is a really special one.
It's going to make me cry, this one.
A classic marzipan is a carefully
kneaded mix of eggs,
sugar and ground almonds.
A traditional recipe that Mak has
decided to ignore.
I think I'm the only baker
doing pistachio.
I've always felt... Urgh,
a yuckiness about almond marzipan.
Mak is a management accountant for
a housing association
and keeps bees with his eldest son
Zafar on their allotment in Bolton.
Oh, this looks a bit full.
His pistachio marzipan will
wrap orange
and spiced stem ginger sponges.
And my kids, they're the same as me.
They don't really like almond
marzipan, so I thought, "Hey...
"..pistachios."
I'm measuring some orange liqueur
to a part of my marzipan.
Good boy, well done!
Hermine is a trainee accountant
and lives in west London with
her son Stephen.
Watch what you're doing.
In the marzipan for her chocolate
orange Battenberg,
orange liqueur won't be the only
surprising ingredient.
I'm making it with some marmalade.
Marmalade in the marzipan?
Yes, instead of eggs. Interesting.
I've never made a Battenberg before.
That's handy. You've practised
it, though?
I did, it's not my area of...
Expertise. Expertise. What is your
area of expertise?
More French patisserie.
We look forward to great
decoration on this, then. Hopefully!
THEY LAUGH
Bakers, you've only got half
an hour left.
We don't mean half an hour to live,
we just mean half an hour
until the end of the challenge,
so don't panic too much.
One of you has got half an hour
to live.
A Battenberg must have a sharp
symmetrical design... Voila.
..which can only be achieved with
patient and precise cutting.
Lovely. A crispy cake. We'll cut
it off,
we'll cut it off. No-one saw.
Apart from the cameras.
Just measuring it with a ruler
and going with the flow.
MARK: It's all about precision,
this one.
If you get the measurements wrong,
when you put them together,
they might be oddly out of shape
and the Battenberg
wouldn't sit right.
OK. But to erect his temple...
3.3.
..Rowan has more cutting to do
than anyone else.
Here we go.
I've made this box out of...
..a CD storage thing with various
cuts, but slots in at different
levels to give me the right-sized
bits of cakes.
There are 13 different pieces,
so hopefully it will work.
So warm.
But Lottie isn't ready to
begin cutting...
Making the marzipan, it's not
a skill I need,
I don't think really,
moving forward.
..and now she's not
the only baker...
I'm praying that it cools down.
..fretting about time.
Oh, I'm really worried at this.
That's not cooked enough. How long
have we got left? 24 minutes.
Oh, for goodness' sake.
The largest sponges for Rowan's
temple are raw in the middle.
I think I'm going to put a cake in
the microwave.
Cos they're cooked in the middle.
Try and cook the centre that way.
Is this just going to be a disaster?
We've got to roll out
the meringue... Uh, the marzipan.
That goes to show how much
I like that.
Rolled too thick and the marzipan
will overwhelm
the flavours of the bakers' cakes
and fillings...
Oh, please taste nice!
..but too thin and it will crack as
they wrap
it around their Battenberg.
I've added a little bit of rose
water in there.
Rolling out balls of chocolate
marzipan, and that's going to make
a sort of polka-dot effect on
the outside of the cake.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
Moment of truth.
Just spreading on some buttercream.
Whilst the delicate process of
construction can begin for some...
The aim is to get the edges sharp.
I think they're going to be
looking for a clean cross section.
No pressure.
I don't think it's great. I might
have to simplify my design.
The temple might have to go!
..as Rowan's plans get less
ambitious... OK, what am I doing?
..despite being behind,
Lottie's rhubarb
and custard Battenberg seems to be
getting more and more complicated.
Everything that is so easy at home
suddenly becomes an absolute
nightmare when you're in the tent.
How many minutes?
Seven! Seven!
God! Right, here goes nothing.
Paul and Prue are expecting
a flawless wrapping of marzipan.
The marzipan is going to
join at the bottom,
so the seam of the marzipan
shouldn't be visible.
Maybe just a more blocky shape.
Ooh! I'm really sticky.
It's cracking in some areas.
How long?
Must be three minutes now.
Come on, come on!
Can't complain.
Hey, Lottie. Is this a critical
moment? Yeah, it is, yeah.
Thanks for coming round, Noel. Yes.
Why did I put a really intricate
design with minutes to spare? Yeah.
Looks good, though. Thank you.
You're going to wrap this around
that when that's done?
You're nailing this.
One minute remaining.
Maybe take the clingfilm off.
A bit of stardust on there.
Bakers, your time is up!
I'm not displeased with
that, actually.
We don't have to wash up. Oh, yeah!
Go on, your turn.
The bakers will now face Prue
and Paul for the very first time.
Hi, Peter. Hello. Hi, Peter.
I like the overall look of it.
It's very neat.
I love the polka-dots.
Love the texture
of the chocolate one.
It's both crumbly and moist,
which is quite difficult to get.
Nice, thin marzipan.
The chocolate's got a lovely
flavour to it, decadent.
And, actually,
it's the same with the orange.
Gluten-free flour for sponges
really does work.
That's a great Battenberg.
It is delicious.
Well done, Peter. Thank you so much.
Well done.
It is very neat, isn't it?
Good orange flavour.
I just question the
ginger with the orange,
and then on the outside,
the pistachio.
It's too complicated.
The almond marzipan would have
been better than the pistachio.
That looks very striking.
The decoration's very neat.
The marmalade brings a real
bitterness to the marzipan.
It blends the orange
and the chocolate together
so it's never going to be too sweet.
It really is a pleasure to eat it.
Oh, that means a lot! Thank you.
You've done a good job.
The one thing I think you expect
from a Battenberg
is incredible neatness.
You've got no real distinction
in the colours of the sponge,
but your flowers look quite sweet.
I'm getting a plain sponge
and the raspberry. OK.
And that's pretty much it.
Really nice, square edges.
The coffee overpowers the chocolate.
It's delicious, actually.
You can't really get the booze.
It's a beautiful coffee
and vanilla Battenberg.
I think you explained it wrong.
It's lacking identity. Yeah.
It's just unfinished. Yes.
Oh, we have the St George flag.
It's over baked.
It's bone dry. Yeah.
I wish we could give you marks
for your handsome cousin.
Oh, he's lovely.
It's certainly striking.
I can smell the bubble gum!
I was about to say...
But that's a good thing. So can I!
That's a good thing!
I'm almost rolling it around my
mouth to try and blow a bubble!
I reckon if I did long enough,
I probably could. That's bone dry.
The flavours are intense.
You know, I love bubble gum,
I like cream soda,
it's just that you needed to be
a little bit less heavy.
And it's really thick, the marzipan.
I do rather like it, I have to say.
When I have my ninth birthday party,
can you cook for me, please?
I will try not to over bake
the sponges, so we've got a deal!
It's a nice, light sponge. It is
a little thick, but I like marzipan.
Pomegranates don't do anything,
flavour-wise.
There's pistachio in
the green sponge
and that brings a lovely
texture to it. Thank you.
If Fanny Cradock was going to do
a Battenberg,
that would be it!
Is that a compliment? Yeah, no...
I think it's a bit too busy.
Good, strong, sour cherry.
Fantastic, that's good. Lovely.
There's too much rose water.
Right, OK.
Shall I open it for you?
Yeah, please, yeah.
I like it wrapped up like a sweetie!
Oh, I love your stripes.
The starburst... Yeah.
..it's a little bit messy.
Was it warm when you were doing it
and it was melting? Yeah.
The colours are really wonderful.
I like the cake.
They both taste the same,
is that meant to? Yes...
The yellow is supposed to be
a custard.
They both taste delicious,
and the same.
The rhubarb jam that you've made
is nice and strong.
And there's enough acidity in it
to cut the sweetness.
It's a really good effort. I'm
struggling not to eat a bit more!
I might just... Do you want to...?
Yeah, I might just stay here and eat
while they... You're more than
welcome! ..they judge everyone else.
I had to change the design
at the very last minute.
So no temple, then.
It's a deconstructed temple.
I think the night sky
looks quite effective. Yes.
And actually, it's quite neat.
I can tell straight away,
by the way the knife goes through,
that that's quite a heavy sponge.
It's a bit hard work for cake. OK.
It feels like there's moisture
in there
that still needs to get out. OK.
That looks really pretty. Thank you.
I like the decoration.
I like the fact that you've glazed
it, as well... Thank you.
.cos that, again, sets it off.
All the flavours are there.
I think the texture is very good.
It's very neat, I like the marzipan.
Individual elements are good,
including the buttercream.
I think it's a lovely piece of cake.
Thank you so much.
What's the stalk made from?
You're not meant to eat that!
No, I know that now!
LAUGHTER
It's cloves. Cloves? So your
mouth's going to be numb, now.
Yeah, my mouth tastes of Christmas.
Yeah. Sorry.
No, it's fine, cos the cake was
delicious so I don't mind.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
Thank you. Thanks.
Half of the Battenberg is on
the bottom of the oven.
Not great.
It's like toast, it's horrible.
But it turned out OK.
Yay!
That couldn't have gone much better,
I don't think.
I'm really pretty amped about that,
yeah.
Oh... Breathe.
I was aiming for middle-of-the-road,
and I think that's what I got.
Don't want to make a name
for myself, first bake.
It wasn't a resounding success,
but I thought it was useful.
NOEL: Each week, the Bakers'
second challenge
will be a gingham covered mystery.
It's time for your first
Technical Challenge,
which comes courtesy
of Paul Hollywood.
# Hurray, Paul Hollywood! #
So, Paul, any words of wisdom?
This is a classic.
We're testing you on your timings
and your consistency,
so read your recipes carefully.
Very helpful. Basically,
"Read your recipes."
As ever, this Technical Challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're going to have to ask these
two lovelies to beat it.
Off you pop.
Paul Hollywood would like you
to make
six miniature
pineapple upside down cakes.
Each should be topped with
a fresh pineapple ring
and soaked in caramel syrup.
You have 90 minutes.
On your marks...
Get set... Bake!
I absolutely love
pineapple upside down cake.
My dad and my husband love it.
So I've made it a few times.
I think I've made pineapple
upside down cake in school.
In each Technical Challenge,
the bakers are given
identical ingredients
and the same pared down recipe.
I've actually never made this
before, funnily enough.
I've never even tried one.
I've heard of pineapple
upside down cake.
I've not eaten one, I don't think.
This is a classic bake.
Pineapple upside down cake
is something I used to have
with school dinners,
many, many, moons ago.
It does look lovely.
Shall we taste it?
It's light, buttery, but also,
you have the perfect caramel.
If it goes too dark,
it's too bitter.
But if you can't see the caramel,
you're not going to be able to
get that caramel flavour.
And also, the worst thing
is ripping the sponge
when they're trying to get it out.
Getting it out of the tin is
where most people come unstuck,
because the caramel sticks to the
edge and it's really difficult.
Going to be interesting, then.
I don't want to eat all this,
cos then I've got 12 to come.
I can't resist it.
Ditto.
The first step is, for the syrup,
tip 30 g of caster sugar
into a pan...
And add two tablespoons of water.
Place over a low heat and stir
until the sugar dissolves.
Increase the heat
and cook to a golden caramel.
The caramel can crystallise very
quickly.
I'm trying not to stir it,
but equally, I need it to hurry up
because I don't have all day.
I've not made many caramels, so...
..slightly nervous.
So how's it going?
It's a case of multitasking
and keeping my eyes on the syrup.
If you pull this off...
I might just make it to next week!
The dry blue cake might
become a distant memory!
No, I think that one will
be haunting me for a while.
Remove from the heat and carefully
pour in the boiling water.
Stand back, as the caramel
will spit a bit.
And then I'll reduce that
and simmer it
until it is a syrup consistency.
You need to hurry up.
I'm fairly happy.
It's looking a bit blonde,
so I need to take the syrup
that little bit further.
It's kind of getting close. I'm
going to turn it down a little bit.
It looks like it could burn me.
It might be a bit too dark,
I'm not sure.
It did smell like it was
just about to burn, but...
..happy with it.
Now I'm on to the very instructional
stage of "Make the sponge."
So that's butter and sugar,
and you beat it until it's light.
And the eggs.
Add a little bit of flour as you go,
because it can just curdle
a little bit.
I'm going to try
and not have a dry sponge.
Prepare the moulds.
So I've just lined them with butter,
just make to sure
I can get them out.
Divide the syrup
and place the pineapple ring
and a maraschino cherry
into each mould.
So, syrup in first...
And then the pineapple.
I'm not quite sure what quantity
I'm supposed to put in, though.
The level of syrup has to be
precise.
I don't know
if that can go on there.
WHISPERS: That can't go on there.
Too little, and the cake won't
have the decadent caramel flavour
that Paul has demanded.
Try and get them all even.
But too much, and the liquid will
prevent the sponge from rising.
Whoa.
Possibly too much caramel.
Haven't read things very well,
have I?
Might have gone over a little bit.
Yikes.
So I'll need to weigh to make sure
that I've got equal amounts
of batter.
Can't be doing with the fiddling.
So you'd rather make one, big,
massive one? A massive tray bake,
to feed people. Like, a huge
one we could all sit round? Yeah.
Like a table. Just tear chunks off.
Exactly.
Like sort of wild... animals.
Animals. Yeah.
So I'm using a piping bag,
cos it's just a wee bit faster
and cleaner, hopefully.
Get ready to go into the oven.
So in it goes.
NOEL: 45 minutes remaining.
How long do they go into the oven
for? You just watch it.
This is where I'm guessing.
I don't know.
No. Well, don't look at me.
I haven't got a clue!
OK.
I'm going to start with ten,
give them a wee check.
Like, 15 minutes?
I made a rookie error.
Didn't butter the moulds.
They're more than likely
going to stick.
Bakers, you've got 15 minutes left.
They smell cooked.
Well, I think they're cooked,
but they're not up
where they should be.
Yeah, far as I can tell,
that's good.
They smell about right.
They look good. Look at those!
You've got skills! I hope so.
I wasn't sure, earlier.
SHE LAUGHS
I'm joking. What do you want me
to do with that?
No, I'm going to... No, I'm going
to take... You can't, it's hot.
Just throw it behind you, like that!
Just throw it,
someone will deal with it.
You don't have to deal with that.
No. You're a baking superstar.
Well, they just sunk,
so they've not worked.
Oh, gosh. They're like toffee.
It's too much syrup,
that's what it was.
Shall I do that thing
that people do on Bake Off?
Just do this for a little while.
Does this work?
Do you think this works?
Give it a waft.
A bit of waftage.
How long left?
Bakers... You... have... five...
Minutes... Left.
Still quite warm. Oh, dear.
Yeah, I think
I should turn them out.
Moment of truth.
That's one that's good,
but the pineapple didn't come out,
so we're on a rescue mission.
Oh... Oh!
That's better.
SHE LAUGHS
They're not even going to come out,
I don't think.
Better than it might have been,
put it that way.
It would have been nice to have
nice, clean sides,
but I didn't grease my moulds.
They would have been even if
I'd managed to carve it out nicer.
I could just shape that like that.
Oh, they are a disaster,
aren't they?
Bakers, you have one minute now.
Going to pipe the rosettes on,
and I think they're good.
Put a bit of cream
and a cherry on top.
I don't think they'll be
cool enough.
It's too hot.
Oh, that one was not ready.
The cream's starting to fall off.
Bakers, your time is up.
Oh, my cream just fell off.
Please place your pineapple
upside down cakes
on the gingham cloth
in front of your pictures.
What a hideous cake.
Oh, think I deserve a cherry.
Look at this. Oh, no!
Go away...!
Oh!
No!
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
Whoa...
I'm so sorry. There was a fly.
I went to blow it away
and I knocked it. Look.
Don't worry about it. It's fine.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sure they can go by
what they looked like
before I brought them over.
Let's just tidy it up.
The good news is, the front two are
absolutely fine,
and we'll tell Paul what happened.
Oh, don't cry, it's all right.
It's OK. It's such a problem to
happen to someone.
Yeah, I know. You know what?
He's OK.
Total accident, isn't it?
It happened. Accidents happen.
I blame Matt, really.
It was actually my fault
because I was looking at you
at the time it happened.
And I think you were probably
hypnotised by my beauty.
THEY LAUGH
Maybe.
I think this is what happened.
Paul and Prue are expecting
six identical pineapple
upside down cakes,
topped with caramel,
cream and crowned with a cherry.
And they'll have no idea
whose is whose.
Oh.
Shall we start over here, Prue?
It's got a nice height to it,
hasn't it?
And it's about the right colour.
I think the cream was going on
when they were still hot.
Let's have a look.
Nice and light. Very light.
Well balanced.
Again, it's the heat, you can
see where the cream has melted
and it's slid off the top.
Good flavour, that cake.
It just doesn't look great.
These do look neat.
Colour's good and it's pretty
uniform as well across all six.
The balance between the sponge,
the cream... It's good, isn't it?
..and the syrup together,
the balance is good. It's lovely.
Moving on to number four.
Again, problems with the heat.
Coming out of the tin,
just needs to be higher,
just a little bit more open.
It's a bit doughy.
Now, these look quite neat,
the cherry sits well on the top.
Nice colour.
And they are pretty uniform.
Lovely cake. It is a nice cake.
Moving on, now,
looks quite dark in places.
That caramel is a bit dominant.
Because it's a little darker.
This, on the other hand,
is a bit too pale. It is pale.
They were rushing.
They brought it out too early.
Put the cream on
when it was piping hot
and then just poured off the side.
It does not look a pretty thing.
It doesn't.
I think, if you get it
a little browner,
it takes away from some
of the sweetness
because the caramel has that tiny
little bit of bitterness. Anyway...
We are going from pale to very dark.
Now, this one has got an issue with
the sticking in the tin,
but also, that's too dark, really.
Yeah, it's a bit too dark.
It's quite bitter. Mm. And there's
a lot of caramel. It's burnt.
And then we move on to one that's
probably just in the middle.
And looks really nice.
I mean, the piping is good,
the caramel colour is good,
they are even, they're all risen.
The caramel is just the right level
so it brings in the colour,
the flavour.
I've no problem with that at all.
Moving on to this one.
The piping is very good.
The piping is excellent.
It has been put on
when it is relatively cool.
It's well-balanced, that.
We have some caramel... It's lovely.
It's almost toffee-like. Mm.
And it balances beautifully
with the sponge.
Now, we move from the sublime
to number 11.
Issues bringing it out,
issues with the sponge...
Didn't rise enough in the first
place. Getting it out of the tin.
Too hot when the cream went on.
What has happened to this? I don't
think it's properly cooked, is it?
It looks like it's been pushed
together into the tin.
Now, moving onto the last one,
now, we heard there was an issue
with this one where it was dropped.
This one, being the neatest one,
we'll take that
as a template for the rest.
They look quite dark down the side
there. Almost burnt.
And that's not
because it was dropped on the floor.
That's because it's been over
caramelised. No.
They've got a nice height to them,
though.
Mm. Delicious.
Paul and Prue will now rank
the cakes from worst to best.
In 12th place is this one.
Oh, Linda. Well, you know what?
There is only one way now is
up from here, isn't it?
11th spot is this one. Very bitter.
The caramel had gone way
over the top.
You had a bit of a problem
with it sticking.
And then, number ten,
is this one. Loriea.
This is the opposite of that one.
It's just a little too pale.
Dave is ninth, Mak, eighth,
Marc is seventh,
Laura sixth, Hermine is fifth
and Lottie is fourth.
In third spot, we have this one.
Good consistency across the board
and the sponge was very, very good.
And then, in second place...
..we have this one. Who is that?
Peter. It is pretty well faultless.
But a smidgen below the winner.
Which leaves first place. Well done,
Sura. They are very, very good.
The pipework was beautiful
and smooth.
The sponge, the caramel,
well done.
APPLAUSE
It was bittersweet because I feel
so sad for Dave.
Pete did really well.
I wish it didn't happen,
to be honest.
It was a bit of a crackerjack
of a day, I think, yeah.
I'm pretty pleased.
Don't like making big mistakes.
And that was a big mistake.
They asked for a pineapple
upside down cake
and I give them a pineapple fritter,
didn't I, really?
There's just one
cake challenge remaining
before we crown
this year's first Star Baker
and reveal who will
be leaving the tent.
So, Bake Off's got a new home.
We're filming in a bubble.
I tell you what, I'm quite
anxious about being locked up
for weeks on end with you three guys
and there's not a grown-up
among you.
HE LAUGHS
No. I was really looking forward
to spending time with you, Prue.
You really were? Yeah.
I love how you two pretend we don't
all live together in real life.
THEY LAUGH
You've got some real
talent in the tent.
Sura was a deserved winner
in the Technical. You've got Pete.
Hermine, I think she's in line for
Star Baker as well.
So, who do think is in the bottom?
I think Loriea,
she had that bubble gum idea.
I think Marc E and certainly Linda,
but there's a lot in the middle
that could go either way.
It's very tough, isn't it?
Somebody's on through lockdown,
and they've come here
and they've quarantined and they're
just in the competition
for two days.
I think that's always the worst
is to go home right at the
beginning. First.
We'll have one big camera
and they'll just walk off into the
distance, socially distancing with
that music from the Hulk at the end.
Yeah.
THEY HUM TUNE
Bakers, welcome back,
and I hope you're ready for your
very first Showstopper Challenge.
Paul and Prue would like you
to make a cake bust
depicting your personal celebrity
hero.
Your 3D cake bust must have a head
and it must be made...
THEY LAUGH
..and it must be made
mainly from cake.
Although you can use some other
edible details.
OK, you've got four hours.
On your marks. Get set. Bake.
Right, let's go.
SHE SIGHS
OK. Roll my sleeves up.
I am petrified
about this Showstopper.
It's just
got so many things happening.
It's given me quite a few
sleepless nights, this one.
To make a cake bust head
and shoulders of a person,
we're asking them to be engineers,
decorators, and bakers.
The big risk with a challenge
like this is ending up with too
much icing, too much buttercream,
which will be too heavy,
make it too sweet,
even if
it makes it look fantastic.
For me, the secret with this
challenge is
which structure they're going
to use to put the cake onto.
If they don't have a decent
structure or
they don't bake the sponges
correctly, it will collapse.
Hello. Hi, Prue. Hello. Hi, Matt.
Tell us all about your bust.
What you going to be doing?
OK, I'm doing David Bowie
as Ziggy stardust. Perfect.
Ziggy Stardust is going to be
instantly recognisable
just because of the colours. Yeah.
A fondant lightning strike
will decorate Marc's chocolate
sponge and vanilla
buttercream reimagining
of the Thin White Duke.
One of the most wonderful
things about David Bowie
is the shape of his face
is so beautiful and so...
It's quite slender.
The first time I made him,
he looked more like Desperate Dan.
NOEL: And Bowie will be joined
on stage by another musical legend.
My hero is Bob Marley.
I just love his ethos
not to worry about stuff.
I've been singing it all morning.
# Don't worry about a thing... #
SHE LAUGHS
MATT: After a difficult first day,
Linda's hoping her lemon
and orange sponge Bob
will be her redemption song,
filled with lemon and orange curds,
and a coconut rum mascarpone cream.
Is the alcohol there for Prue?
HE LAUGHS
Well, I thought it might
cheer Paul up.
HE LAUGHS
Nothing cheers Paul up.
How much booze you got in there?
A couple of bottles?
A bottle and a half. Have you?
SHE LAUGHS
No!
And if that doesn't get
the backstage party started.
Ay-oh!
I love Freddie Mercury.
You're a big Queen fan, yeah? Yeah.
NOEL: Laura's lemon and elderflower
Freddie Mercury
will take to the stage in a highly
detailed fondant icing replica
of his iconic yellow jacket.
So, you've practised this cake.
The last time I did it, they head
exploded and it went in the bin.
Right. Yeah. Cut.
SHE SNEEZES
Bless you. Too much chilli.
Hello, Loriea. Right, Loriea.
Who are you going to be
doing for your bust?
I will be doing
Miss Louise Bennett-Coverley.
She's a Jamaican poet and she's got
a poem about identity.
And I've got a mismatch of accents,
which I think works well for this.
Loriea will celebrate
her Durham and Jamaican roots
with a chocolate sponge
with scotch bonnet chilli
and spiced ginger and mango jam.
I have practised this multiple
times.
And I think my first attempt,
it looked like I created Dobby,
so you will get, hopefully, a better
version of something like that.
Hi. Hello.
I hear you're doing David. Yeah.
Is that because you pushed his cakes
over?
No! No! No. Sorry, I got mixed up.
Who are you doing?
Sir David Attenborough.
What a ledge. He is a ledge.
Do you love him? I love him so much.
Have you ever met him?
No. Of course I'm not met him.
He's coming today.
Of course he's not.
I texted him. Oh, sure.
I said, "Sura needs you."
I do need him. I need a life model.
MATT: Sir David will
be flavoured with coconut
and layered with raspberry
Italian meringue buttercream.
People won't mind
if you get it wrong,
but the animal kingdom
will be furious.
Well, we can't have that.
There'll be voles, gerbils...
Coming for me!
..marmosets coming for you.
The odd pigeon.
SHE LAUGHS
Good luck! Stop it.
MATT: But Sura's Sir David
will have a rival.
I'm doing a cake bust
of Charles Darwin.
Uh-huh.
I studied zoology at university
and I thought the Bake Off tent
is a little bit like the survival
of the fittest, so... True!
THEY LAUGH
Mark will carve a spiced ginger
sponge with coconut buttercream
into a simple stone-style bust
of the pioneering naturalist.
I'm not a really decorative baker.
I also quite like the idea
of doing someone who is not alive
so I can't offend them.
HE LAUGHS
Whilst Lottie's chosen hero
is very much alive,
it doesn't look like it
at the moment.
I have a skull mould which I'm going
to just build on top of,
because that's what's underneath
someone's head, right?
Lottie's coconut and lime skull
will be transformed into
a spectacled bust of Louis Theroux.
You know he was on Bake Off last
year? I do, yeah.
So, actually,
with Louis having been on the show,
you two guys will know how
he tastes. Yeah, yeah.
He tastes a little bit coconut-y,
doesn't he?
I think it sounds delicious.
Thank you. I hope so.
# Please cook and be nice,
and don't BLEEP. #
Building a bust out of cake
and several sponges...
More sponges than a Turkish bath.
..of varying sizes and shapes...
They're in.
..is creating a time management
nightmare for the bakers.
I've got two timers on the go. One
for the oven and one for my task.
It's very complicated, isn't it?
But Rowan's hero demands something
even more elaborate
than multiple sponges.
I am making Queen Marie Antoinette.
Oh. So there'll be a chocolate cake
with kirsch-soaked cherries
and then I'm making choux buns
to make Her Majesty's hairdo.
Whilst her choux hairdo might
prove complicated,
things should be simpler
with Marie Antoinette's face.
It's a good idea with the mask in
the silicon mould,
because that'll give you an instant
image anyway... Yes, yes.
so you've got something to work
from. I hope you do it justice.
Absolutely. Thank you. Good luck.
I'm just laughing to myself.
"You must be completely mad."
HE CHUCKLES
Massive dash against the clock.
Completely bonkers.
Who in their right mind...?
Yeah, I don't know why.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
I just have so much to do
and I'm just really aware of
so many different multiple elements.
Next, I've got to make
coffee mascarpone cream
to go between the slices.
NOEL: As well as helping to
hold their busts together...
So I'm going with raspberry
Italian meringue buttercream.
..the bakers' fillings
are another chance to deliver
show-stopping flavours.
This is my lemon and elderflower
mascarpone cream filling.
I'm not having him say that
my cake is bland today.
This is ginger and mango jam.
I'm using a lot of ginger.
MATT: But Peter is taking
a more subtle approach.
Between the cakes,
I'm just going to have a nice,
simple strawberry jam,
and some whipped double cream.
It's a family favourite.
The simple theme will continue
between Peter's Victoria sandwich
rendition of his cycling hero,
Sir Chris Hoy,
sporting fondant goggles and helmet.
That's a clever way of
getting round doing hair.
Precisely why I wanted to do it!
And also goggles.
Yes, yes. So, no eyes.
I'm not great at sculpture and art,
so I thought I'll go more simple,
and try and get something that
presents well.
Well, good luck, Peter.
Thanks very much.
Right, are we ready?
I think that is, like, just cooked.
Yep.
Sorted.
Oh, he's got a lot of sponge. Mm?
He's got a lot of sponge. I know.
The sponges might be
out of the oven...
This bit is so stressful.
It's so hot.
These are hot cakes.
..but until they're
cool enough to carve...
Pop them in the fridge, because
I can't do anything with that,
because they are still very warm.
..assembly will have to wait.
Oh, no!
I just lost a sponge.
Ah, damn it.
I just dropped a sponge.
It's fixable, I think.
I think I can use it for the top,
so it's all right.
I think I'm doing OK for time.
I'm just trying to roll out as much
fondant as I can
before the cakes come out
of the freezer.
Using fondant will allow the bakers
to craft the skin, hair
and clothing that will hopefully
bring their heroes to life.
So I'm making beads
for her necklace.
Who's this? Prince Charles?
No...
Shall I just keep guessing?
It's meant to be Tom DeLonge.
Farrah Fawcett? Who? Tom DeLonge.
Blink 182?
Oh, I know who they are, yeah.
Are you a fan of that type of music,
Noel?
Er, yeah.
No.
Fondant ears and a highly
detailed fondant face and cap
will cover a strawberry,
chocolate and mint homage
to Dave's favourite punk icon.
Do you know what music Matt likes?
Well, when I first met Matt,
he was listening to Roger Whittaker.
Mm-hm. Do you know him?
This is actually true.
No, I don't know who he is.
# I'm going to leave old Durham town
NOEL LAUGHS
# And the leaving's
going to get me down. #
You were trying to block that out
a bit, weren't you? Roger Whittaker.
You were hoping that would end.
# Back in 1944... #
I don't really know who he is.
I'm just using the pasta roller
to roll my dress.
Wow. I'm doing Lupita Nyong'o.
She's a Hollywood actress. Yes.
Black Panther. Yes.
Very beautiful girl. She is.
I hope, er, I could replicate that.
Hermine is aiming to capture
Lupita's beauty by decorating
her chocolate and coffee sponges
with fondant fabric
and very lifelike facial features.
I'm going to make ice mould eyes
to give it real eye look.
I hope it will look impressive.
Also keen to do his hero justice...
Two eyeballs.
Some cheeky things.
..is Mak.
My hero is Bill Bryson.
He's an author I've admired
for decades.
I've been studying his face so much.
Honestly, I just know every little
wrinkle, every nook and cranny.
His lemon Madeira sponges
will form the base for his
anatomically thought-out bust, and,
to recreate Bill's flowing locks,
he has a special tool to hand.
It's a press for making Bombay mix
and things like that,
and basically what I'm trying to do
is just create strands of hair.
Very nice.
Can you make me some, please?
Well, just come over here,
and I'll just... Yeah.
Yes, please. Yes. Thank you.
But things aren't going quite so
well at Rowan's hair salon.
No, come on, choux buns.
Why?
I'm hoping it will rise. We'll see.
Bakers, you have one hour remaining.
Oh!
You haven't seen my rolling pin,
have you? No, not anywhere.
I'm going for the assembly.
I'm dreading this bit, actually,
because it's...
..oh!
With their sponges cooled,
the build can begin.
I'm not running any risk of anything
slipping off the mat.
I'm feeling a little bit nervous now
about time,
cos these need to be, like,
really frozen,
but I think they're cool enough
to carve.
Here we go...
Stacking layers of delicate sponge
and creamy fillings
is a precarious task.
It looks a bit like I'm performing
some awful medieval torture,
but it is a necessity, and I'm sure
Louis would understand.
Well, I've got some choux,
very flat choux,
so it will be a matter of
whether it's worth using or not.
I don't want to be criticised for
my choux when it's not necessary,
so I'll just, I'll wing it,
as usual.
As the busts get taller...
The head's starting to droop
forward.
..and heavier,
the strain on the sponges...
It's all kind of cracking.
..starts to take its toll.
This is going to collapse, I think.
Oh, it's a wobble.
No!
Oh, this is stressful.
Some of Freddie Mercury's head
is not there.
That ain't meant to be happening,
is it?
Oh, flipping heck!
Bakers, you have 30 minutes left.
It's surprising how the time
just flies, doesn't it?
When you're having fun.
Who just said they're having fun?
OK, I'm just going to
have to go for it.
God, have you ever been more
stressed in your life?
Yeah, I've never been this stressed,
mate.
As the fondant goes on...
Speak to me, Mr Bryson.
..engineering makes way
for artistry.
To do this to your heroes
is fairly horrendous, isn't it?
Mine doesn't look anything like him.
It's just scary.
Just so stressful, Paul.
Why on Earth did I get into this
competition, I don't know.
You chose to come here.
I know I did!
THEY LAUGH
What the hell is that? This?
It's like a death mask!
Who is it, the Grim Reaper?
Erm, it's supposed to be
Louis Theroux.
Rude!
Rude. Have you ever seen
Louis Theroux?
I have faith he's going to stand up.
Oh, he's got the shortest
head in the world. Oh!
Embarrassing.
Making boobs on national TV.
I don't know if I've ever fancied a
cake before! But I slightly do now!
We've decided to go for rice paper,
given the disaster
with the choux buns,
erm, this seems like
the best option.
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
It's just not enough.
It's just all gone wrong.
Kind of like a bandanna,
I'm trying to put on there,
but it never seems to work
as well as I need it to.
I'm just going to quickly
paint his little eyes in.
Oh, man, he looks absolutely
knackered. Poor David.
I like detail. It's calming.
Time factor-wise,
I think it's just going to have to
be kind of silhouette-y, really.
I can't do it. You can.
I can't do it. I can't put
the head on. What do you need?
What do you need? I'll help you.
I've got to put the head on
but I can't do it.
I'm too scared.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Do it! Oh...
Oh, just put it on, put it on.
Come on, Freddie,
please stay together.
Oh, my God, Louis, please don't
hate me when you see this.
Rowan, can I be of any assistance
for the last wee bit, or not?
I think I'm kind of there,
actually, thank you.
I'll just do a bit more
pinning of these things and then...
Quick, quick, that just needs to
sit on top. It's not going on top.
Oh! You've put the wrong bit in.
I just need to get some glasses
on him.
As long as that just holds up
for a little bit.
Oh, no, Freddie!
You've got to laugh,
he's got a bloody hunchback.
Quick, quick, quick!
Quick, quick, quick! It's too big,
it's too big, it's too big. This
bit, this bit, this bit. Go, go, go.
OK, it's going to pierce through
his head a little bit. It's fine.
I don't care.
Bakers, your time is up.
Thank you SO much for your help.
Step away from your cake busts.
Well, it wasn't quite what I had
planned, but you know, what is?
I'm going home. No, you're not.
I am. I'm truly going home.
That was hard. Tell me about it!
Oh, my God, yours is about to
fall off! Oh!
No! No!
I've never run!
sponsors The Great British Bake Off.
CLATTERING
Sura, get something flat.
It's not in balance.
It'll fall again.
That's it. Something heavy.
Stand it up at the back.
That's it.
I had to put, like,
the piping bags behind them,
so it looks like a travel cushion.
It's all right. He said you can use
inedible supports.
HE GIGGLES
It's judgement time
for the 12 cake busts.
Rowan, would you like to bring
up your Showstopper?
The choux buns were a bit of
a disaster, so I had to improvise.
There's a pattern forming here,
because you promised us
almost the Parthenon yesterday
we didn't get.
You promised us choux buns
we haven't got. No.
Say less and then do more. Yes.
THEY LAUGH
Having said that, you instantly
recognise who it is.
I think it's absolutely brilliant.
Thank you.
I just hope she tastes nice.
Well, so do I.
Going to go through her cheek? Yeah.
No!
Oh, you brute.
HE LAUGHS
It is a chocolate cake
with kirsch-soaked cherries.
Mm. Cherry flavour's lovely.
Would have been nice
to have the choux buns,
but, overall, I think you've made
a very tasty cake.
Thank you. Well done, Rowan.
Well, I have to say, he is
recognisable. Definitely.
Thank you.
That sort of slightly anxious look
is very Louis Theroux.
It is a coconut and lime sponge
with a chocolate orange buttercream.
You get all the flavours.
The orange, the lime, the coconut,
but it's over baked. It's bone dry.
It's obviously Bill Bryson.
I do think it's good,
I love the detail on it. Thank you.
And what's inside it?
It's a lemon madeira
with redcurrant jam.
Lovely flavour. But it's very dry.
And that's a real shame.
I'd like to have seen a mouth on it,
because obviously, you know,
Marley was known for his voice
and he hasn't got a mouth.
THEY LAUGH
I actually think it's delicious.
It is.
Thank you. It's got all the elements
to a very, very good sponge.
You can't go wrong with citrus
flavours with a lemon curd
floating through it.
It's very dramatic.
He's got these wonderful
athlete's shoulders,
he really looks as if he's puffing.
And I love the helmet.
It's clever and it's a good get out,
because wearing a helmet and a mask,
you know who it is.
I mean, Sir Chris has got
many, many Olympic medals,
and that's what he was wearing
when he did it. It's excellent.
Let me just... Sorry, Chris.
I was quite worried about this,
because I thought,
Victoria sandwich and fresh cream
is all quite light and easily
squashed
and you'd end up
with a sort of pudding inside.
But you haven't. It looks lovely.
The Italian meringue
buttercream is delicious.
The strawberries, the cream,
the sponge is spot on.
Mm. And it feels really fresh,
doesn't it? Light. It's delicious.
The concept is great.
And it's witty.
Well done, Peter. Well done, Peter.
Thank you so much.
Well, I think
it's like a caricature,
so it's really good. Thank you.
Would you like to tell us
what's inside it?
Mint and strawberry
with a cocoa butter cream.
A bit toothpaste-y.
The mint is so strong
and it has that very chemical taste.
It's a shame. Yeah.
You let yourself down a little bit
on the texture and flavour.
Yeah, OK.
Erm...
That's about as far away
from David Bowie as you could get.
I'd agree with you, actually.
Yeah, he's lost his neck.
Yeah, yeah. More Jabba the Hutt.
THEY LAUGH
It's a chocolate sponge
with vanilla buttercream.
It's quite dense.
It's slightly overbaked. OK.
But it's a great flavour.
Good effort. All right, thank you.
Thank you.
The fact that you've put "Guess who"
on this makes me think that you
don't think that looks like her.
That's right.
Your work with the fondant
is absolutely exquisite.
I actually thought it was real.
Thank you.
So, let's hope it's as good
inside... I hope too.
..as it is outside.
Mm.
It's really lovely.
It's such a rich chocolate cake.
It's delicious.
Thank you. Yeah, I'd sit down,
have a slice of that any time.
You can see who it is.
It looks great. Thank you.
This is a ginger spiced sponge
with a coconut buttercream.
Lovely. Very good flavour.
It's nice to see that you haven't
really overdone it with the spices.
You've got spices in it,
you can identify them,
but it marries up beautifully with
the ginger,
and it's a well baked cake.
Well done. Thank you.
We've got a picture of her in front
of us now. Headscarf, tick.
Necklace, tick. Necklace, tick.
Resemblance to her... Resemblance...
HE LAUGHS
..does not exist. Not so much.
It has got a chilli chocolate sponge
flavoured with scotch bonnet
chilli powder
and ginger and mango jam.
The chilli's a little bit
overwhelming.
I do agree that you could lower
the chilli a little.
Wow.
HE LAUGHS
It's coming in waves.
But when you've got a wave of ginger
as well, it's really, really strong.
Now, this is lining up with what
happened yesterday as well.
Consistency is the word. There is...
You are consistent, absolutely.
He's a reclining...
He's having a nap.
HE LAUGHS
Very neat on the shirt,
very neat on the face.
And you can see who it is.
Right, let's have a look, shall we?
Gosh, that looks really tender.
It is a coconut sponge
with a raspberry Italian
meringue buttercream.
I like the flavour.
It's not too dry, which is good,
so it's nice and moist in there.
I think, overall, you've done
something that looks like him.
It's quite smart, it's neat.
You've done a good job there.
Thank you.
SHE LAUGHS
Sorry.
You're not supposed to laugh!
It was all going really well.
Like, his jacket looked great
and everything.
And then the head exploded.
HE LAUGHS
I think... Yeah. But I'm hoping
that the flavours will redeem.
And what are the flavours?
Lemon and elderflower.
I do think his jacket is lovely.
Thank you. Yeah.
Mm. That is delicious.
Thank you.
I think one of the reasons
it squashed so easily is
it is very most, isn't it? Mm.
Do you like it?
Erm... Oh, go on, say you like it.
I actually... I love it, yeah. Yes!
The flavours are really good.
The elderflower's there.
I mean, it looks the way it does,
but it actually tastes really nice.
And you can identify who it is.
Thank you. NOEL: Well done.
Well done. Oh, what a relief.
Come on, Fred.
THEY LAUGH
Let's go.
Well done. Thank you.
My biggest fear today was that they
were going to say that
the cake was bland, cos then
I knew I was going home.
I think I've hopefully
pulled it back.
I baked it how I like it,
so it's too late to cross fingers
and toes now.
Kind of thought before that came
together today
that that was it.
But if it is,
I'm going out on a high.
Nobody wants to be the first.
And coming on the show,
I said, "I don't want to be
the first."
But maybe that was my challenge -
to accept being the first to go.
Paul and Prue have
made their decision.
Well, congratulations, bakers.
I have the rather pleasant job
of announcing
this week's Star Baker.
And this week's Star Baker is...
..Peter.
THEY CHEER AND APPLAUD
Which means I've got
the horrible job
of announcing which baker
is leaving us.
And the baker who's going home is...
..Loriea. I'm sorry.
Aw. Aw.
Oh, darling, oh, I'm so sorry.
It's fine. Bless you. Thank you.
It might have been nice
to stay a little bit longer,
but someone has to go, so...
Well done, mate. Thank you.
You did amazing to get here.
Remember that.
Yes, I am proud.
I did quite well to get here.
And I stayed true to myself.
I'm so sorry. It's fine.
It was really sad, actually,
cos I can see a lot of talent
in Loriea,
and what was...
HE SIGHS
As a judge, I can't get involved,
because I want to tell her,
"Stop doing that, stop doing this,"
and it came down to overbaking
and over-flavouring.
Can't believe I'm through
to next week.
I was sat on that chair ready to
stand up.
SHE LAUGHS
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, fantastic.
I can't believe it.
I was like, "Argh!"
Well done. Thank you.
Well-deserved.
I said I was
putting my money on you.
THEY CHUCKLE
Hey there. I just wanted
to give you a quick call.
So, week one went pretty well.
I got Star Baker.
CHEERING, HE LAUGHS
Hooray! Well done.
Thank you. It was...
It's pretty insane.
Next time...
..it's biscuit week.
The bakers start off with
a chocolaty fruity signature.
May the best mango win.
They go for gold in the Technical.
What is golden,
do you know what I mean?
And face a fragile...
SHE GASPS
I might well cry if this breaks.
..3D moulded Showstopper.
Nipple on and a nipple there.
Exactly. They are like breasts.
They are.
Who will be gasping for breath?
SHE GASPS
And breathe.
And who will make the judges blush?
I remember worrying a bit about your
very large nuts.
THEY LAUGH
Because...
Subtitles by Red Bee Media